federal judges or during President Trump
to turn over his financial records to
Congress the ruling is in response to a
power-play by the President to deflect
investigations led by congressional
Democrats Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill with more on this story so Nancy
what does this mean well those documents
be turned over it looks like they're
going to be unless the president wins an
appeal this is very significant Gale
because it is the first federal court
ruling in this fight between the White
House and congressional Democrats and it
is a defeat for the president who has
vowed to ignore all congressional
subpoenas in this case Democrats had
subpoenaed years of the president's
financial records from a czars USA which
is his longtime accounting firm
Democrats want those records because
they're investigating whether the
president committed financial crimes
before taking office the judge decided
Congress has a right to those records
has a right to investigate the president
called the ruling crazy and vowed to
appeal Nancy on that point of Congress's
power to investigate the House Judiciary
Committee subpoenaed former White House
Counsel Don began to testify today does
it look like that's going to happen nope
he's going to be a no-show Anthony and
according to his lawyers he is following
the president's directive here and he's
going to defy this subpoena in response
the committee's chairman Jerry Nadler
said his committee is going to hold him
again in contempt of Congress the reason
Democrats want began to testify so badly
is because they're looking into whether
the president obstructed justice and
remember McCann told investigators that
the president tried to get him to shut
down the probe by Special Counsel Robert
Muller more than once in another
headache by the way for the president
transcripts were released yesterday of
two interviews that the House
Intelligence Committee conducted with
the president's former lawyer and fixer
Michael Cohen earlier this year
Cohen interestingly told lawmakers that
Trump attorney Jay Sekulow encouraged
him to lie about efforts to secure a
Trump Tower Moscow deal during the 2016
campaign now here's why this matters the
president repeatedly said he had no
business dealings with Russia during the
campaign but according to Cohen the
negotiations continued into June 2016 a
Cohen you'll recall initially
followed the president's lead back in
2017 but then changed his testimony
after he was convicted for lying to
Congress seculow is hitting back saying
that it defies logic to believe anything
that cohen has to say Anthony all right
Nancy thanks very much